Hey everyone, Ryan here, and welcome back to our oral medicine series. This video will
be a brief overview of the ASA classification system, which is asked about on the board
exam.
So the American Society of Anesthesiologists, the ASA physical status classification system,
has been used for well over 60 years now, and the intended purpose of this system was
to determine a patient's medical comorbidities before receiving general anesthesia.
So it ranked people from physical status 1 to 6, and the higher you are, the more at
risk you are of having some adverse medical events during general anesthesia, so it enabled
better communication among anesthesiologists. But it can also be applied more broadly to
just get an overall idea of someone's health status and medical risk based on their medical
history.
So let's go through this chart one row at a time, and we start with ASA 1, which is
a normal, healthy patient. So this would be someone who is not a smoker, they have no
or minimal alcohol use, and also none of these other things that we're going to mention
must apply to this patient. So they're perfectly healthy, and I will say this is actually fairly
rare. It's pretty rare to find somebody who falls perfectly in this ASA 1 category. For
this kind of patient, no special precautions are needed for dental treatment.
Then we go to ASA 2, which is probably the most common of all these rows. This is a patient
with mild systemic disease, and they only have to have one of these things. It doesn't
mean they have all of these, only one of them would automatically put them in ASA 2. So
this could be that they're a current smoker. Pregnancy also puts someone in this category,
a well-controlled hypertension, well-controlled diabetes, which means your HBA1C is less than
7% for a current diabetic, their social alcohol drinker, obesity, well-controlled epilepsy,
asthma, or thyroid dysfunction. So these are all conditions that impose little to no functional
limitations on the patient. So elective dental care is okay, but you might consider some minor
treatment modifications. Then we go to ASA 3, which is for a patient with severe systemic disease
that limits activity but is not incapacitating. So this could be stable angina pectoris, which is
chest pain only with a stimulus, like physical activity. A past history of more than three months
ago of a heart attack, stroke, or transient ischemic attack. Exercise-induced asthma could
also fall in here, so a specific type of asthma, an end-stage renal disease where the patient is
currently undergoing dialysis treatment, alcohol abuse or dependence, morbid obesity, chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease, poorly controlled hypertension, poorly controlled diabetes,
HBA1C is greater than 7%, poorly controlled epilepsy, and/or symptomatic thyroid dysfunction.
So if the last category was all about well-controlled diseases, this category is all about poorly
controlled diseases. So for these patients, elective care is generally okay, but there needs to be a
serious consideration of treatment modification. And you can reference some of the things we talked
about in the last few videos on what you might do for a patient at a certain hypertension,
blood pressure reading, or blood sugar reading. All right, now we get a little bit more serious.
So for ASA4, that's a patient with an incapacitating systemic disease that's a constant threat to life.
This could be unstable angina pectoris, so spontaneous chest pain with or without a stimulus.
A recent of less than three months ago, heart attack, myocardial infarction, stroke, or transient
ischemic attack, end-stage renal disease where the patient's not undergoing dialysis treatment,
uncontrolled epilepsy or seizures, and septic shock. I would also put something like symptomatic
hypertensive emergency in here as well. Elective care for these patients is contraindicated,
and as for urgent and emergency care, we want to stick to noninvasive treatment if possible,
so for example medications, or invasive treatment in a controlled likely hospital environment.
Then we go down to ASA5, which is even more serious. This would be a more abundant patient
not expected to survive the next 24 hours without a surgery or operation. So this would be end-stage
cancer, end-stage infectious disease, end-stage cardiovascular disease, end-stage hepatic dysfunction,
or a massive life-threatening trauma. Only palliative care beyond the necessary surgery
is advised. And then just for a complete nessake is a declared brain-dead patient,
whose organs are being removed for donor purposes. This is an ASA6. You won't be getting a patient
case down here. Likely most of them will either be ASA2 or 3. So speaking of which, I have a couple
of example cases that we can work through together just to test your knowledge and go over what we
reviewed in the previous chart. So for all of these questions, we'll be asking what ASA classification
best describes this patient, which could absolutely be something that you're asked on the board exam.
So for this kind of question, if you're somebody who reads the question first and then looks at
the patient box, you really don't care about much of this information up here. We don't really care
about their chief complaint. We're really focusing in on the medical history and maybe some of the
current findings if they include vital signs or blood sugar or things like that. So what we see
is that they have hypertension. And if we sneak down here at the medications, we notice they're
taking two medications that are actually used to control hypertension. So remember, hypertension
is ASA2. If it's well controlled, it's ASA3. If it's poorly controlled. And here's another
gray area. What exactly is poorly controlled hypertension? Now some sources will say it's
anything greater than 180 over 110. Some sources will say it's anything over 120 over 80. In my
hypertension video, we talked about all the official AHA categories. And at what readings,
I tend to implement certain treatment modifications like stress management and slow chair movements.
But I was careful not to define well and poorly controlled for this reason because it is a bit
of a gray area. But now that we've gotten to the ASA video, I want you to have a number in your head
for these vital sign readings. So for poorly controlled, I would go with anything that's 140
over 90 or above. That's going to be your threshold for what is poorly controlled.
So basically stage two hypertension. So we see that this patient has an elevated blood pressure.
We are in stage two hypertension, even with some blood pressure medications. So I would say this
is pretty safely a poorly controlled situation. Elevated blood pressure in stage two, even with
two medications. So this would point them towards an ASA three. The obesity is an ASA two. If the
BMI is greater than or equal to 30, it's ASA three. If morbid obesity or the BMI is the body mass
index is greater than or equal to 40. So this would point them towards an ASA two. But we already
have an ASA three. So that one's kind of ruled out. We're always going to pick the thing that puts
you at the highest category. Then they also have end stage renal disease. So this is an ASA three.
If they're under dialysis and ASA four, if there is no dialysis, well, they mentioned that they're
doing it three times a week, which is pretty standard. So this would also be an ASA three.
So again, if you have multiple factors from different ASA levels, you always go with the highest one.
So the answer here would be ASA three. Let's do another one. So we have a patient here.
We have a paramedic who is bringing this patient in. They were the victim of an MVA and they're
triaging them for immediate surgery. So you're probably in some hospital environment. For their
background, they have a zygomatic omaxillary complex fracture, a ruptured abdominal aortic
aneurysm, multi organ dysfunction. And we don't know their medications haven't been able to find
any current findings yet. So this patient needs immediate surgery to survive. And this is a pretty
unlikely case, unless again, you're in an emergency room, you're in a hospital setting. But because of
the multi organ dysfunction, the massive life threatening trauma, this would be an ASA five,
a more abundant patient not expected to survive the next 24 hours without some immediate intervention.
All right, how about this one? So we have a patient 24 years old here for a cleaning.
And let's go to their medical history. They have type two diabetes. This will be
either two or three for the ASA category, depending on how well controlled it is.
So how do we find that out? Well, we can see they're taking some medication. Glipizide,
that's for type two diabetes. And their blood glucose today is 110 milligrams per deciliter.
And this is a, as far as we can tell, a random glucose reading. So that means we assume it is
not under fasting conditions. We assume that they ate something within the last eight hours. So
anything under 140 milligrams per deciliter is acceptable. So that's pretty good. And HBA1C less
than 7% is considered well controlled for a diabetic. Remember, this is measuring the percent of hemoglobin
that is glycosylated in that blood sample. So anything less than 7% well controlled. So
these are looking pretty good. So we would go with an ASA2 for this patient as far as their
diabetes status. So they smoke cigarettes and they drink socially. Both of those point towards an
ASA2 as well. Now her blood pressure is 123 over 65. There's no mention of hypertension in the
medical history. It is considered elevated in our AHA categories, but it's not over that threshold
of 140 over 90. So I wouldn't consider this poorly controlled. This is just maybe an anxious
patient. There's no hypertension to be concerned about for this patient. So they're at two and two.
So we're going to say they are an ASA classification two patient. So those are some examples. You'll
probably see ASA2 and three most commonly. You might see a four and on a very rare occasion you
might see a five. But that is what you're looking for in terms of analyzing a patient's medical
history and their vital signs or blood glucose or HBA1C. And now you know what all those mean thanks
to the last couple videos. Alright, so that's it for this video. Thank you so much for watching
everyone. Please give this video a like if you enjoyed it and subscribe to the channel for much
more on dentistry. If you'd like to support me, please check out my Patreon page. And thank you
to all of my patrons here for all their support. You can unlock access to my video slides to take
notes on and practice questions for the board exams. So go check that out. The link will be in
the description below. Thanks again for watching everyone. I'll see you in the next video.